oh and welcome to this video playing
bronze storm Bronston yeah I do I
currently don't like my e5 or that much
I get the Italian game every game and
this is just and it's once more once
more probably will play that as well you
know what i relieved cap of the italian
this is fantastic I mean this is not not
a lot that I was that I like very much
this one it's a good good reply to mine
um to my bishop before system but it's
it's really better than then the Italian
ok isn't d5 possible here am i killing
myself here was with no development now
it should be ok right yeah it's it's
reasonably ok
hmm what is actually what is White's
reply actually it's a little bit awkward
yeah the e-file other if I looks looks
like there could be something going on
so takes Knight takes Knight takes
bishop checks well this is this is equal
but it's not nothing special deform yeah
I wonder about d4 here also not sure
okay let's take it spent a bit too much
time again here on this is not some
relevant stuff now it's probably equal
not sure this night only three we should
be form that how that works this is a
good piece position or not probably it's
just eat one
that could be a pretty awful idea just
thinking like doing to put something on
b3 here yeah that's probably not helping
let's just double here gobble on the DVR
yeah no it's not it's not trading down
everything that's just like that one
thing is I would like to go 97 but b7
less actually hanging so it's not that's
not so easy to do how to play
let's gain a bit of space I wonder if he
can actually take it I mean may I can
probably singing 95 maybe some 95 and
then V takes it play some c6 that that's
a bit too fantastic that's probably not
not working so maybe wait a moment and
see if I can maybe get to some ending
where my king is a bit more active 95
knows getting a bit more interesting
still doesn't work rhythm okay maybe I
can provoke him we have King f6 doing
something weird
no I don't think again don't think it
does anything what I did but but Tok at
least you felt somehow provoked to to
take them maybe is checking me and then
takes on d7 and queen h8 that's possible
even though clock Queen d2 probably it
looks like it looks very Jewish actually
clap he cannot move the night I am ok
but still I can do here maybe who ah I
forgot that he can take and play with
the apron well okay i still have 24 I
mean wow really 24 text x 35 text
ex-king is seven can you talking these
successes let's lose the porn so I can
play this move what is he doing here is
that good
and I don't think you can take and I
mean where is he going he did take 95
losers immediately and here this is
should also this shouldn't be good I'm
just not sure if I can witness the thing
hmm yeah the night won't be too might
just maybe some funny maybe I cancelled
swung him somehow but don't see how time
morning
clap what is he doing here for g6 really
chat wow I didn't know if I had a win
and now this should be relatively
straightforward maybe I can put it into
the super strong at the end as possible
but I wasn't sure and here i think it
should be ok should be quite
straightforward maybe this is also works
right check white resides Jeremy that
was compressing water out of stone ok ok
so this line is here with us with Bishop
e3 is not particularly threatening but
it also it's not very exciting Quincy to
maybe I can do something else here that
that makes it a little bit more that
makes it a bit more difficult ok this is
an interesting choice yeah yeah maybe I
should done that so it's a bit more to
be more interesting with therefore may
be coming yeah as you can see the
computer thinks it's roughly equal well
it's a bit more them has a bit more
potential than what I did I mean here I
was just basically laying around and
yeah this was mostly provocation and
just try to provoke him to do something
that I feel that's much to be done just
just wanted to provoke him and he did
something at least like here here here I
know I thought I mean queen queen here I
have Queen d2 then Tom probably doesn't
have a perpetual right again I can go
here yeah you cannot move the night and
without of made and that's the end of it
but he played ok this I went c5 we're
actually it was not aware that if he
takes which which he should do that is
gotten an a porn that's probably Jewish
but this is getting very difficult now
the engine wants to play Quincy one to
defend yeah it's not funny i can can
barely move now i can go over here play
c6 mmm it's not not much fun and here i
actually wasn't sure than winning i mean
this this looks very normal here and now
he went here i went oops sorry age six
top I a check this is losing immediately
he has to just stay somehow and I wonder
here with him yeah h6 hinted at g5 but I
wasn't really sure that would would play
it ultimately probably i would but okay
I can do this also Kingda tongue he can
mean white white has some problems to
make moves that that's very clear
here I've ever at edwins immediately mmm
there really is a borderline anything
it's probably losing for wider thing but
she five takes takes he probably gets
into Duke swung one thing that that
sometimes as an idea is to play the
three and just give the pawn so that I
can enter so what the engine is giving
here this is this kind of thing ok this
is also it suits one position now
probably this is too passive with the
night it was really a strange decision
to play a b5 because this must be better
here this is a I mean it's not like the
pawns sorry for the painting poncey are
falling but they are clearly weaker in
the leg compared to the position with v6
end and mp5 on and the a point is at
least a passer so I mean very likely a
draw this is what the engine at the end
gives you with the draw both kings are
pretty open so the likelihood of some
kind of Perpetual is pretty high okay
yeah okay guys thanks for watching